[Music]
on this Wednesday night what the Prime
Minister knew about Beijing allegedly
targeting a Canadian MP I asked csis you
know what is this briefing plus Justin
Trudeau's brother testifies before the
Ethics Committee
Despair and destruction in flood-ravaged
parts of Quebec
the helpless people left homeless the
premier's morning and the area spared
the Kremlin accusing Ukraine of trying
to assassinate Russia's president the
skepticism and the fears of what Moscow
could do next
and Running on Empty there's a lot of
reasons to be concerned the potential
Ripple effects from an excess of vacant
office space
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
new details are emerging about when the
government learned a conservative MP and
his family were allegedly targeted by
the Chinese government and prime
minister Justin Trudeau is now calling
for ceases to share more information
with the government about any threats
against MPS in the future
when it comes to an MP's safety when it
comes to their family's safety we need
to know even if it's a mild concern or
or something that that wouldn't
otherwise hit a threshold that cesus
would feel it needs to be Mackenzie gray
joins me now what else did the Liberals
have to say well nephew after avoiding
answering for 24 hours today the liberal
said they didn't know about a Caesar's
report alleging a conservative MP was a
target of Beijing I asked ceases no what
is this briefing what is this supposed
story that is out in the media from a
leak what do we know about it that media
report came from the Globe and Mail
saying a 2021 thesis briefing alleged
conservative MP Michael Chong and his
family were targets of a Chinese
Diplomat in Canada because he supported
labeling beijing's treatment of the
uyghurs a genocide Justin Trudeau saying
he first learned about it reading the
globe was it ever briefed up out of
cesus it was not cesus made the
determination that it wasn't something
that needed to be raised to a higher
level because it wasn't a significant
enough concern but Trudeau says that was
the wrong call and ceases should have
told him we're making it very very clear
to csis and all our intelligence
officials that when there are concerns
that talk specifically about any MP
particularly about their family those
need to be elevated Chong had previously
been briefed by cesus but not about
beijing's threats against him and his
family they didn't
tell me about this particular individual
in Toronto Mr Way Joe
and they didn't expel this particular
individual
I understand that there may have been
something offensive said but I have no
idea what the hell it was in a raucous
question period the opposition didn't
buy the government response it is
impossible to believe that he was not
made aware of these threats two years
ago when they were documented by his own
intelligence Services they were asleep
at the switch for 10 years when they had
the reins of government
the NDP said the Chong story underscores
the need to have a public inquiry into
foreign interference a decision that
Justin Trudeau has handed over to former
Governor General David Johnston who will
make that decision on May 23rd all right
and Mackenzie the prime minister's
brother testified today before the
Ethics Committee about a donation to The
Trudeau Foundation linked to China what
did he have to say about this yeah
Justin Trudeau's brother is defending
the foundation for accepting a two
hundred thousand dollar donation back in
2016 from billionaires with ties to
Beijing whose goal was allegedly to try
and Curry favor with the government
but there were a lot of things that I
felt needed to be corrected for the good
work of the foundation to continue and
for all the doubts that are being thrown
around about it to stop Alexandra
Trudeau who's listed as a succession
member of the foundation told the
committee he respected the Chinese
donors and I have no reason to doubt
that this man never tried anything that
would look like interference so I as far
as I'm concerned he's an honorable man
despite that Trudeau believed the
donation didn't impact Canada China
relations there was no foreign
interference no possibility of
interference
no intention or means of interference
there was nothing there there is nothing
there please investigate us
the Prime Minister did meet with those
Chinese donors but his brother says that
Justin Trudeau was not involved with the
large donation in any way and hasn't had
any association with the organization
since he was elected liberal leader
which undercuts a conservative attempt
nephew to tie the foundation directly to
the Prime Minister Mackenzie gray in
Ottawa thanks Mackenzie
in Quebec police believe a body
recovered this morning is likely one of
two missing volunteer firefighters the
pair was Swept Away by flood waters
during a rescue on Monday the region has
been devastated by heavy rain this week
damaging critical infrastructure and
forcing hundreds of people from their
homes Mike Armstrong reports
the water swept into this neighborhood
Monday in minutes people were told to
grab a bag and leave some didn't even
have time for that
there was a river in the street this
woman says we left with nothing
the premier toured Bay St Paul Wednesday
reassuring some and warning others about
50 homes were destroyed some won't be
allowed to rebuild in case the land
floods again some problems maybe South
some Maybe not maybe we'll have to ask
some people to to move the search
continues for one of the local
firefighters lost Monday the pair had
just helped airlift a couple to safety
when they were Swept Away themselves one
of the bodies was found Wednesday
morning
police say crews are still searching for
the other from the air on the ground and
on the water now Bay St Paul has been
the worst hit area but there are spots
like this almost right across the
province mostly brought on by heavy rain
days
in the LA energia region Northeast of
Montreal several towns have declared a
state of emergency travel in the region
has been Complicated by washed out roads
water levels are still Rising off the
West Island of Montreal the bridge to in
Mercier has been closed it's a small
community of about 50 homes they are for
now accessible only by boat
although this woman did Cross by foot as
police tried to stop her
she says it was safe but that she was
told she's going to be ticketed water
levels are expected to stop Rising
within the next 48 hours there's clear
weather for a week after that dikes are
still being raised higher in some areas
but the Region's being on flood alert
since March 18th the fire department
says the work that's been done has so
far paid off as for now we don't have
any evacuation we don't have any houses
that have been flooded the city of
Gatineau has about 330 people who've
been forced from their homes three
ferries have also been suspended because
the water they travel across is too high
Mike Armstrong Global News Saint
Rodriguez Quebec
multiple regions in BC are also on alert
for Rising Waters
there are now evacuation orders for
multiple homes in the village of Cache
Creek in the province's interior it
declared a state of emergency earlier
this week due to Rising flood waters
which have already destroyed one
property rapid snow melt and upcoming
rain threatened to overflow rivers and
creeks in Central and Southern BC
potentially endangering more communities
to a disturbing case in Ontario now
where a Mississauga man is charged with
two counts of counseling or aiding
suicide police say 57-year-old Kenneth
law is suspected of selling and
delivering sodium nitrite a substance
dangerous when taken in large doses to
people at risk of self-harm on top of
that his alleged crime could also
involve an operation spanning dozens of
countries across the globe microwlay
reports
Tom parfitt was a young man consumed
with anxiety when he took his own life
in 2021 he was found in a UK hotel with
a packet of sodium nitrite by his side
but when his father asked for answers he
got none unfortunately the police was
showing no interest in the UK about this
that seen it as just you know Tom taking
his own life I
I had a feeling it was something more
than that I had a feeling that someone
had assisted his suicide so he began his
own investigation discovering online
forums detailing how large dosages of
sodium nitrite a salt compound used to
cure Meats could be used for suicide and
Not only was it legal it was easy to buy
online
the times of London dug a little deeper
alleging the sodium nitrite legally
purchased by parfitt's son came from a
Mississauga Ontario company run by
Kenneth law who until recently worked as
a chef at the Fairmont Royal York Hotel
on Tuesday he was arrested and charged
by peel police who alleged he was
actively marketing and selling his
product to people at risk of self-harm
we've identified two victims both in the
in the regional pill and they now want
to hear from anybody who received
packages from other companies linked to
law including M time Cuisine and Bucca
academic Escape mode and Ice Mac we're
aware of 1200 packages that have been
shipped how many contained sodium
nitrite police aren't sure what Suicide
Prevention experts know is that they're
seeing more of the product than they'd
like but the real concern is how suicide
is marketed online I
patients that call it suicide porn and
they tell me that they're like addicted
to these m
is and this conversation uh and it's
really hard for them to disconnect from
that because it's an endless supply of
information
um imagery a reality that complicates
the Mental Health crisis microlay Global
News Toronto
if you or someone you know needs help
you can call talk suicide Canada at
1-833-456-4566 support is available 24
hours a day every day of the year
Canada has pledged 71 million dollars in
humanitarian aid for Sudan and two
neighboring countries dealing with a
large number of refugees in the wake of
violent clashes International
Development Minister harjit sajan says
the funds will provide basic food water
and Health Services
this rapidly changing situation Canada
is ensuring that our funding remains
flexible to allow our partners and host
Community to respond to evolving needs
on the ground and to tackle new
challenges as they emerge
fighting between the Sudanese Army and a
paramilitary group continue despite the
declared extension of a ceasefire deadly
violence erupted more than two weeks ago
at least 550 people have been killed
Russia is accusing Ukraine of trying to
assassinate President Vladimir Putin
Moscow says it downed two drones over
the Kremlin overnight as Eric Sorensen
explains Ukraine denies the claim and
warns Russia may be preparing to launch
a large-scale terrorist attack in
retaliation
it was a spectacular site a drone
destroyed above the Kremlin at 3 AM the
question was it a real attack or was it
staged there are questions around the
timing of different videos and whether
those are people on the roof when it
happened today Russia accused Ukraine of
trying to assassinate President Vladimir
Putin Ukraine's President visiting
Finland denied it even suggested Ukraine
doesn't have the resources to do it we
don't attack
Putin or Moscow
are we fight on on our territory we are
defending our religious and seated we
don't have you know enough weapon for
these the U.S Secretary of State said he
could not validate the Russian
allegations I would take anything coming
out of the Kremlin with a very large
Shaker of salt a Kremlin statement
called it a terrorist attack quote the
Russian side reserves the right to take
retaliatory measures where and when it
sees fit former president Dmitry
Medvedev went further posting there are
no options but the elimination of
zelenski and his Clique an attack by
ukrainians can't be ruled out but is
unlikely says this analyst it would seem
far more likely that it is some kind of
either false flag attack or something
designed to provoke and rally the
Russian population that would be an
official Ukrainian initiative in spite
of massive damage and casualties
inflicted by Russia Ukraine has been
preparing for a spring offensive
just days before Russia marks its annual
Victory Day on May 9th a purported drone
attack could give Vladimir Putin a boost
among the Russian people try and rally
them behind the president because there
is a fear among the Russian leadership
that the population is going somewhat
disaffected with the war If This Were a
real Attack the bigger story would be
that Ukrainian partisans or Russian
dissidents penetrated Russia's security
and air defenses the concern in the west
is that Russia may be preparing to
justify an assault on the Ukrainian
capital and on President zielinski
himself Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
Serbia is in shock and mourning tonight
after a deadly massacre at a school
coming up how police say a student
plotted the attack
a mass shooting at a school in Serbia's
Capital has left eight students and a
security guard dead a 13-year-old
student has been arrested police say the
boy confessed to the attack which he had
planned for weeks and made a list of
children he wanted to kill investigators
say the teen was also carrying two
Molotov cocktails and used his father's
handgun in the Rampage his parents have
now been detained
in Texas that massive search for a man
accused of fatally shooting his five
neighbors including a young boy over a
noise complaint last week has ended last
night police followed a tip and captured
38-year-old Francisco oropeza he was
found hiding under laundry at a home 16
kilometers from the crime scene the
accused Killer's wife was also arrested
and charged with hindering the suspect's
apprehension
in Brazil's capital police raided the
home of former president jair bolsonaro
today and arrested two personal aides
part of a probe into falsified covid-19
vaccination records
that's bolsonaro telling reporters he
has nothing to hide but the
investigation could help answer
questions about how the far-right former
leader a covid-19 skeptic who vowed
never to get the vaccine became
registered as vaccinated while he was
Brazil's leader
out of office ahead how Rising living
costs are fueling a commercial real
estate crisis
in a bid to cool persistently High
inflation the U.S Central Bank hiked its
interest rate for the 10th time in 14
months the U.S federal reserve raised
the key rate by a quarter point to 5.25
percent a year ago it was one percent
this also marks America's highest
interest rate since August 2007. similar
interest hikes here in Canada have also
made it difficult to afford real estate
it's not just a matter of Canadians
being able to pay their mortgages either
the commercial real estate sector is
feeling the squeeze of rising costs as
agaviola explains its problems are only
getting bigger as businesses find fewer
reasons to need an office
the pandemic turned Toronto's once
bustling Financial District into a ghost
town most offices have reopened but
hybrid and flexible work models are the
new Norm in many workplaces across
Canada and Beyond vacancy rates for
commercial Office Buildings are high and
economists are worried there's a lot of
reasons to be concerned about the
commercial real estate sector less
commuting is better for the environment
easier on the pocketbook and could mean
this trend is here to stay employers are
realizing geez this is a huge expense
this building where I bring people in
every day five days a week and I can
save an awful lot of overhead if I can
get out of those leases or ownership and
have the people work virtually there's
all sorts of incentives like free months
friends other inducements to kind of get
tenants in and that to me is where it's
signaling that there's been a shift in
the marketplace many feel this is just
the beginning of a real estate Reckoning
that's going to profound only impact the
market value of these buildings and
there's going to be bankruptcies there's
going to be failures Economist Carl
Gomez warns of a price correction of as
much as 50 percent nobody really knows
if that's going to you know happen
instantaneously or over a period of time
some see an even bigger change in the
U.S market Charlie Munger the right-hand
man of legendary investor Warren Buffett
this week warned there's a lot of
trouble in Office Buildings shopping
centers and other properties the 99 year
old billionaire said there's a lot of
Agony out there he worries U.S banks are
full of bad loans on Commercial
properties an ominous warning is
American financial institutions
experience upheaval vulnerable to the
pressure of high interest rates and
waning confidence the loans are very
very big you know office properties
trades in the in the hundreds of
millions of dollars so there are
knock-on effects that happen to the
broader economy when something as big as
that starts to you know feel distressed
distress over lower demand for Office
Buildings like a canary and a coal mine
perhaps a sign of bigger issues to come
and gaviola Global News Toronto
next the massive security preparations
and planned protests ahead of the king's
coronation
[Music]
with large crowds set to line London
streets for the king's coronation
Ottawa is warning Canadians about
traveling to the UK over potential
terrorism threats yesterday Buckingham
Palace was locked down over a security
incident now police say they'll be out
in full force and using facial
recognition software on the crowds
Saturday's ceremony will involve the
biggest Security operation in British
history Crystal gemancing Reports on the
preparations
under the cloak of Darkness operation
golden orb glittered the First full
dress rehearsal along the coronation
procession route for the thousands who
will be taking part and so the
opportunity to take part is something
that we relish and it's a great
opportunity to do a fantastic juices for
the king
Canada has a contingent of 45 Armed
Forces members in the military parade
the rehearsal covered the full
procession route to Westminster Abbey
and back lasting several hours the royal
family was also spotted at the Abbey for
their own rehearsals around all of the
key locations there are onlookers and
police for those in central London a
warning for the Metropolitan Police
Service they say there will be a low
tolerance for any sort of disruption at
the coronation 29 thousand police
officers will be deployed over the
course of the holiday long weekend
Republic campaigns to abolish the
monarchy Graham Smith had anticipated up
to 1700 people out along the coronation
procession route but fears a chilling
effect as officers now have more powers
under the public order act we're going
to be contacting everybody to reassure
them for us the police are being very
clear that they have no problem with our
plans and won't stop us
the new law prohibits
disruptions the disruption Smith says
he's planning involves people wearing
bright yellow holding banners and
chanting not my king the aim is to make
this impossible to ignore and I think
we'll achieve that something they've
done many times before but how people
will react to them during the coronation
is the question
commencing Global News London
and Global News will have further
coverage of the king's coronation on
Saturday Donna Friesen will be live in
London at 5 a.m Eastern 2 A.M Pacific
right here on global Donna will also
bring you global national from London
tomorrow but that is our newscast for
this Wednesday I'm nitu karcha tonight's
your Canada is Victoria Prince Edward
Island we love seeing your Canada please
email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching and have a great night
[Music]